many people are still in the dark about
what to do our national correspondent
Jericka Duncan spoke to a Detroit family
now mourning a man they say was turned
away from getting tested three times
Keith gambrel says he was concerned his
stepfather 56 year old Gary Fowler had
coronavirus gambrel says he took him to
the ER three times and says each time
Fowler was not admitted and not tested
despite having many of the symptoms the
day before Fowler died his father David
died from Kovan 19 soon after Fowler's
wife Cheryl began having symptoms of her
own landing her in the hospital
gambrel was concerned other family
members could be next so we called this
cousin state representative Karen
Whitsett Whitsett who visited the White
House last week to speak about surviving
coronavirus made sure her family was
tested if not for your title as state
lawmaker do you think your family would
have been able to get tested absolutely
ma'am and that sickens me to have to use
that title to be able to do to have to
get my family tested my brother Troy
tested positive for it my brother on
Monday Michigan's governor created a
state task force to investigate racial
disparities in the pandemic lieutenant
governor garland Gilchrist is the chair
one of the things that we are addressing
with this task force is the fact that
there may indeed be medical bias present
when it comes to testing as in who is
who will even get a test as well as in
how treatment is administered gambrel is
now focused on caring for his mother
Cheryl she had been sent home from the
hospital but was readmitted late last
night on what would have been her 25th
wedding anniversary having been through
this what
you say to people who are losing loved
ones back-to-back just pray just got to
continue to fight for them and live the
life that they will live and be their
voice someone has to speak for the
people that can get medical attention in
the proper way and I feel like that's my
duty now and I just spoke to gambrel
this morning he says his mother is still
in the hospital as we speak the governor
there in Michigan says that the state
has the capacity to test 11,000 people
each day but she says right now they
don't have enough reagents and swabs so
they're testing at half that amount such
an important part of the storage Rika
thank you very much